welcome everybody once again
thank you very much for joining us in
these uh
virtual events this is now the second
part
of the uncle mine world oaten
event and now we will move on to the uh
to another section uh we'll have two
more speakers
now the first one is dr javier
nandeslosa who is currently the director
of the molecular biology laboratory at
voldemort hospital
in spain and the second uh presentation
will be given by
dr ines ranieri who is the staff
pathologist at the institute of
pathology
medica a gay in switzerland
the first presentation will be about the
ngs
evolution in solid tumor genomic
profiling um
uh avira actually will tell us a little
bit his experience
about using the s5 excel
and the second presentation will be
actually
on the first experiences using yonko
mine
comprehensive essay plus uh
with this i also like to remind you that
right after these two presentation we
will have a q a session
and uh the speakers will be in the
position of answering to your questions
for now i would like to start with the
first presentation
please go ahead dr javier hernandez
lawson thank you very much
hi good morning my name is javier
hernandez
i'm currently the molecular biology lab
director
in the hospital universitary baldwin
in barcelona spain the title of the
speech is the ngs evolution in solid
tumor genomic profiling
this is a my disclaimer and then i
divided
the speech in two different parts
the third is our diagnostic laboratory
and gs experience
and then the second part is the most
clinical research
part of the ngs that we are running
right now
in the last one year so
first of all who we are we stay here in
a big hospital in catalonia in barcelona
it's balderbrom and in baltimore you can
see
the department of pathology there are
three buildings with more than
20 specialist pathologists including in
the
in the lab and also another research
institute
just behind to perform different
experimental designs
so in the experimental branch we have
a molecular lab this is a translational
molecular pathology lab the chairman
and the department is dr ramon
and also beyond of this clinical
research and translational research we
have a molecular pathology lab
these molecular pathology labs there are
at least currently more than 30
different
molecular techniques plus 25
in situ hybridization tests and more
than 30 pcr
designed for a clinical diagnosis
and we are also running over 16
000 samples per year in addition
we are not only doing the analysis for
the patient from our institution
but also in spain we have we are on a
reference lab
who are receiving samples for other
hospitals vision of that
and then also for different ways we have
a
reference center with different
companies and also
the main idea is to
standardize the molecular techniques in
those samples
uh perform some efficacy in the samples
management
reducing the turnaround time in
different biomarker testing
and finally to be cost effective
in the consume of gradients
so in different biomarkers we have
established different algorithms
mainly we receive samples from non-small
cell lung cancer colorectal cancer
and melanoma samples and in base of this
algorithm we can develop different
analysis
based on immune chemistry based on fish
or based on pcr or qpcr
finally in some of them we are using ngs
to perform more broadly analysis in the
same samples
as a reference lab we always stay uh
uh deciding which is the best technology
in each biomarkers
on one side we have a clinical validated
analysis and a standard criteria to be
positive or negative analysis by phase
or in mr chemistry
but also we incorporate in additional
tests
such as mgs rt pcr ldtss or
nanostring for example with a more
objective
interpretation we are covering more
potential usability of different
rearrangements
but in contrast we often a clinical
validation pending and also there are no
standard criteria to use those analysis
so as a result why we use ngs analysis
from my point of view the ngos analysis
are more
related in three different aspects one
is
accuracy accuracy diagnosis such as soft
tissue tumors or pediatric tumors
biomarker testing or translational
research
first of all in the soft tissue
sarcomas in our center we have found a
clinical center
who are collecting not only criteria for
pathologists but also for the clinicians
we often
selected as a reference center in soft
tissues
in spain so based on the morphology data
inclusive within the specialist
pathologies
there are also 25 or 30 percent of the
cases that are discouraging cases
because it's based on the experience of
these
pathologists and the expertise of the of
each of that
so as a result the molecular analysis
based majority of them by certain
rearrangement
maybe is worthy to incorporate this
microanalysis in order to solve these
discrepancies
why we use ngs and how to deal with the
rearrangements
there are two main ways one is dna base
or rna base from our side
we prefer rna base in order to
avoid sort of large introns repetitive
introns
or many complex genomes events between
the exons for the different genes
involving this rearrangement so in our
experience
we are using a platform for mds in order
to adequate and to characterize the
right rearrangement so we are covering
unknown and non-replacement and also
this is the presentation
with a software specific for describing
these rearrangements in the bottom part
you can see the cosmic presentation for
the transcript that we discover
and also additionally in some cases we
are validating with our tonal techniques
such as fees at least for example in
some
if we have available for these props
in our experience we are running 91
samples
there are 52 now fusion
but 36 is efficient and only for invalid
results due to a low quality
of rna extracted in our experience the
majority of the ewing sarcoma
anal alveolar sarcoma and other tumor
types
who are different rearrangement
described in the epi chart
the most important thing here is that at
least eight percent of the samples were
currently identified by ngs and some of
them
has modified the original version of the
diagnosis versus the finer version
of the diagnosis in our case
we have an internal molecular pathology
board
so this is one per month 48 hour before
sequencing results this is an internal
meeting with
specialist pathologists who are ordering
the different tests and also
in this meeting we have the specialized
pathologists and as a molecular
biologist
to discuss all the molecular analysis
beyond of the ngs
fees or qpcr or whatever in order to
define what is the
concordance of discordant results with
the morphology
safe to the non-small cell lung cancer
in our experience
this is the workflow that we have
established for different samples
to arrive at our lab to perform the
molecular profiling in this tumor type
we are cutting eight slides and staining
the first and the last one as such as
hematosilineosim in order to confirm the
tumor content in each of these slides
and also the two former issues including
an extracted dna for efr mutation but
single gene approach
arc growth and visual intestines are
screening diagnostic chemistry
and in some cases if we need to confirm
or fix analysis while using the last
extra slides
so why ngs in known as muscle lung
cancer
one of the reply is to perform a
molecular profile in these tumor types
in this review we can identify
so the earlier stage or the metastatic
stage
the different alterations that we can
find
in those tumor types and as you can see
in ufr
keras bruff is the most important one
but there are
many many other alterations such as
amplification and rearrangement
to be very very important in this
molecular profiling
to do that the best way is to choose
the gene panels so at that time
you need to define what is your interest
if you are interested in the
class 1 actionable mutations only
or you can go to the class 2 or the
clinical relevant alterations
or move to the class 4 in order to
describe more discovery in these tumor
types
once you have established your intention
the second
option is what is the technology that
you are using
or amplicon site or hybrid capture
so both of them have pros and cons you
need to analyze
in your site what is your pros and cons
in the amplicon you are defining very
well your
applicants and but on the other hand
you have more error in amplification
and sequencing having said that
at that time in our site we decided to
move
uh to a panel who incorporates
a class one actionable mutation and also
combining dna
and rna from the same samples uh
in the same assay in the same same so
uh in this case we decided to use
uncommand solid tumor
who are developing this the
these genes to include for the dna
mutation
and also we are performing rearrangement
for
all red cross and enter one
and also the most important thing also
is that there are very few
amount of dna or rna as i input in this
assay
importantly also is not only for the
known
fusions in those genes but also
through the imbalance that is provided
for the kid
you can also recognize another
alterations involving these genes with a
partner that are unknown
so we use the ion reporter this is the
software provided by thermo to use this
analysis
and applied by different filters you
have discovered the variants that you
will find
with those samples in our case we are
starting with a
different type of material we have uh
started with
different samples for surgery samples
for cytology samples or small biopsies
and also introducing some external
artificial control
and also we are using a different
type of dna extraction and also
erroneous suction
so the idea was to know exactly what's
going on with these panels
in our plethora of samples arrival to
the left
and also comparing these the gold
standard analysis
so such as air by eu formulation
immense chemistry and fees with the ost
in these panels we observe on a 100
concordance in this alteration that we
have observed previously
in terms of egf permutations and also as
you can see in the table
in the last part we found also
additional alterations that are not
covered at the beginning because we are
comparing the data only for the gold
standard
such as typically mutations
and keras mutations and other
alterations very very important in this
tumor type
so in our experience we have analyzed
more than 176 samples
and this is the uh alterations that we
found in our experience for the research
so this is the tale for the cancer
where discover the most frequent
alteration is tb53
following by k grass and ufr as
described in other series
of other hospitals
well at that time we are not alone
in the community so based on the
results that we are observing in
[Music]
labs within the europe and out of the
europe there are some
organization in terms of the
coordination in the lab performing
ngs analysis mainly and
more importantly in the france
experience from the institute national
cancer the inca models they design
specifically 28 laboratories to perform
ngs biomarkers testing
with a high level of quality criteria
and terms for the equity in the whole
populations
we tried to do this in our country in
spain several years ago
with unsuccessful results but moving
forward in this molecular world
we decided to start a huge project
at least in this community in catalonia
with seven
hospitals that are coordinated by x the
institution catalan de la salud
the main idea is to shift
from the current technologies that i
explained before mr chemistry
sequencing phase or gpcr for the next
coming technologies
in some of these seven hospitals
the next common technology are using ngs
are using digital pcr and also
nanostream
to perform not only molecular studies
in terms of research but in a future why
not
incorporating our armament for them
pathology report this is the ideal world
so
one reference lab within this project as
a sex
for different technologies in order to
choose what is the best technology in
terms of whether the biomarkers that you
are
planning to map and also not only from
paraffin samples that is our
standard but also why not the next one
is liquid biopsy
our recent clinical research and use
experiences
okay uh we acquire in in our
lab also the ions five plus
uh ion chaff and the reason was mainly
to perform this
testing biomarker in a small cell and
cancer and present some data before
and also um in arrangement
or in agreement sorry for an agreement
with another
uh laboratories within our institutions
as an example for example we are in
contact with our pediatric research
group in order to
starting some projects regarding how
implement this ngs analysis in our lab
and now beyond for the standard criteria
right now
we are running some projects we are
using whole exon sequencing
in some high risk for pediatric tumor
but we need to externalize
those samples for a company and this is
uh
30 days later they back the results
and then we need to move uh for a
quicker way in order to understand if
it's worthy or not and we are planning
to incorporate the childhood here and
also for example in agreement with
hematology
they are running some research and some
milot panels and they are
using this equipment so the idea is not
only
acquire the equipment for our
installation but also to sharing this
as a codelab here and also
within this project that i mentioned
before for the x project
we took advantage to incorporate
genetics
in this acquisition the main restaurant
was to
optimize the workflow so we have
at least the workflow established in the
four samples per lane so this is a very
flexible workflow for us
there are a full automation so for us it
is very essential because
this is not dependent for the high value
of the technicians here
in my institution uh we are reduction in
the turnaround time
of the orders and also a possibility to
combine
the parking samples and the future
liquid biopsy that we want to
incorporate in our labs
so to do that uh this was the
the main project but of course the covet
infection and the pandemics are right
and also in spain's arrival as a tsunami
it's not a wave it was a tsunami
so at that time we have different
challenges
one is the installation there are some
accessibility
to the lab there are some reduction
uh we need to install the genexus they
install the software and also set up the
machine
um having say that there are no special
attention for the engineer team
here that uh jaime vitherso is the
special thanks here
because he stayed with us to set up in
during the whole process
but also there are some uh webex
or some software that are solving part
of our
initial programs such as life lens
or rescue software so
the first approach was to use
samples that we are doing that we had
used
previously by ngs analysis and run with
the
oppa the uncommand precision assay
in this table you can see that the
main alterations was the same
like we have expected to find
a such query p53 egfr
etc that's also the most important thing
is that when we compare
exactly the same analysis with the
previous method by ngs
not only found the same alteration that
is expected
but also the allelic frequency variance
was very very similar so here you can
see
that the distribution is very very low
so as a result and also
to summarize uh we are using
oppa for this previous analysis and in
our research
also we found a malignant singular tumor
as an example
that we perform different music
chemistry and we found that
entrance expression we use the open
analysis
uh to to to know if it's
uh n-track fusion or not and we observe
it
that the entrance fusion in this part we
observed an imbalance in the entract3
so thanks for the open analysis
we can confirm that the end track was
rearranged in the entractory gene
here uh to final my my presentation
i would like to present you on a short
video less than three minutes in order
to know and to show you what is the
workflow
for the next coming month when we
incorporate the oppa
in our analysis for the starting form
for the arrival samples
to the end
[Music]
[Music]
so
well so having said i haven't seen
this video my take home message for this
presentation is that
at least in spain ngs are broadly used
in oncology with great experience in
clinical trial for screening
monetarization and translational
research
that ngs is implemented in clinical
practice with
small and moderate panels focusing how
to spell mutations
and rearrangement and also finally the
technology improvement
and the increasing automation process
such as the nexus
are essential for the future
incorporation of ngs technologies in
pathology lab and
using different tumor types vision of
the non-small cell lung cancer
but probably next coming tumor types are
essential to be
mapped by ngs so final question
this is the lab for the molecular lab
for the people who are doing this ngs
and also thanks for all of you for your
attention
so hello everybody well first of all i
would like to
thank the organizers of the meeting for
inviting our institution to give this
talk at this virtual meeting
and um i'm minis rainery i'm a
pathologist also training molecular
pathology
and i'm happy to present to you our
first experiences with
uncombined comprehensive asset plus for
comprehensive genomic profiling
i do not have any conflict of interest
to
these close except that a honorarium is
provided for the presentation
now to give you an introduction to the
topic i just would like to briefly
go over timeline of some of the
highlights of precision oncology
research probably the precedent
is the treatment of estrogen
receptor positive breast cancer with
tamoxifen
however the first truly molecular
targets were
also in breast cancer her2 amplified
breast cancer which responded to trustus
work
and also the treatment of bcr able
translocated chronic myelogenous
leukemia with the
imaginable later it was found that
etf4 mutated adenocarcinomas if the lung
responded to tk interpreters
that k ras mutated other neurocarcinomas
of the colon
responded less well to egfr inhibitors
and that melanomas with b-raf mutations
b600 responded very well to
b-raf inhibitors to this point basically
we one was looking at single genes
in very distinct entities however
thanks to genomic profiling of a lot of
different
tumors mostly partici it was found that
a lot of tumors
actually shared common drivers and
the idea of tumor agnostic therapy
evolved in tumor agnostic therapy you
don't anymore
look so much at brother tumors from and
what
histology is but you look at the
pro-molecular and phenotypic profile of
the tumor
today there are two truly
tumor agnostic approaches which are
fda approved one is the treatment
of all msi high tumors with
immune checkpoint inhibitors
irrespective
of whether they are from colon from
endometrium or from any other site
also in 2019 it was a proof
that an amtrak fused
tumorous irrespective of the rather
childhood adults
carosomas carcinomas or sarcomas
could be treated with specific
inhibitors
if we are looking at the oncology
technologies and the requirement
landmarks it's certainly
ngs massive parallel sequencing
which led the foundation to our current
genomic profiling of tumors and without
ngs we wouldn't be
where we are today and indeed several
platforms have been developed
and are in the meantime approved by the
fda
and also by for
medicare and medicaid patients
if we look at the advantages of
sequencing
panels now we save material which is
frequently very limited
always consider that we are frequently
dealing with very small biopsy specimens
and cytologists samples next
we save time before
sequencing was often done in sequential
order
when we did standard sequencing for
example in adenocarcinomas of the lung
it was first tested where the mutations
in etfr or
k-grass are present the two most
frequently mutated genes
and only if these were negative then we
would perform cyanosequencing of other
genes
third there is a growing number of
actionable targets and we just
couldn't actually efficiently address
these anymore by zenith sequencing
alone and then lastly because
it was as already discussed we know that
with there are
recurrent genomic aberrations across
very different tumor types
the workload has increased and we can
look in very rare tumors whether there
might be
some target which could be relevant
for the patient now
if we look at uncle kb we find that
actually we have
at the moment 42 genes for which an
fda approved drug is present
now these 42 genes of course could be
easily covered by a small sequencing
panel
but tumor mutational burden has started
to be of
interest because it is one
of the parameters which basically
predicts
where the patient might respond to
checkpoint inhibitors or not
high tumor mutational burden in breast
cancer
and colorectal cancer is actually
approved for checkpoint inhibitor
therapy also
micro satellite stability is an issue
as already mentioned this is a true
tumor agnostic
therapy of course we easily can perform
immunohistochemistry for mmr proteins
but sometimes we don't even have
enough slides to do that and we will
have to rely
on a dni based test
and lastly there might be only 42
fda approved genes but if you look at my
cancer genome
we find actually that there is an
abundance of clinical trials and at the
moment
there are over 9 000 phase one two phase
four trials
which are which look at very different
targets
we think that this graph actually
outlines very nicely why
is good to have a wide
sequencing panel this is by vega
doll sanchez from 2018 from cell
and they looked at the 10 most
frequently mutated pathways in cancer
now if you just take the receptive
thousand kinase ras pathway you see that
the two most frequently genes
mutated genes are k ras and b raf
however
you might have mutations in rare genes
just
such as sus1 or araf and they
also may be potentially interesting and
might be potentially targetable
and if you have a small panel you just
lose these actually these authors have
find
found that within these 10 pathways you
have 51 percent of the patients they
screened
had one target present and if they
expanded that to
ms uh to bragginess and to idh1 and two
it was
57 so you have actually considerable
number of patients where you find
a target if you use a broad sequencing
parallel
now genomic profiling in clinical
research
and on a very small scale that's
probably what we do
or how our laboratory evolved has gone
on in many other places
we started out doing her two
immunohistocanistan fish in breast
cancer
and gastrointestinal cancer patients we
moved on
to sanger sequencing in for example lung
cancer or colorectal cancer
and as our workload increased we started
to do small c
small targeted gene panels uncomment
from cross assay
and soon it came obvious that clinicians
were interested in researching wider
panels especially breconness
but also tumor mutation load and we
started to apply
these panels and
we decided now to try to implement the
oncoming comprehensive plus
essay in our laboratory in this essay
you have over 500 unique genes which you
can profile for mutations for fusions
and for copy numbers and
in this talk i only will talk about the
dna part of the test
but you also have a multi-biomarker
profiling
looking at micro satellite instability
tumor mutational burden but also
mutation signatures
you have a really low dna neurone
input as far as 20 nanograms which helps
a lot if you're giving
small samples you have a high sequencing
rate
and you have a dedicated bioinformatics
suit
which leads to reduced stat for
reporting
and which can be applied in a routine
laboratory
for our setup to um look at the aside
performance
we actually started out with 21 ffp
tumor samples in 16 and in between there
are actually 17 samples we
know microsatellite status either by
immunohistochemistry or pcr
in eight samples we had previously
performed tumor mutation load assay
and in all the samples of course we have
detected variance s and v's
and copy number variations if you
look at our samples you see actually
that we have quite a variety
we had five other carcinomas of the
pancreas we had colon
lung but we also had rare cancers just
such as
one carcinoma of the adrenal gland or a
poorly differentiated neuroendocrine
carcinoma which was
not further specified and we actually
chose the samples based on that we
either had tumor mutation load data
or we had a high number of or a
relatively high number of variants to
compare
if we look at msi status that's how we
routinely do it we do either
mmr immune histochemistry you see here
another neurocarcinoma the colon
staining for
all mmr for mmr proteins that are
usually screened for
and or we do msi pcr using the podesta
panel
and in a dash edition nr21 and a 24 and
27 markers so we're actually looking at
eight
markers now
comparing our data to occur plus data we
had
two cases which were msi high and these
both these cases display the loss of
mlh1 and pms2 by immune isochemistry
in one case we also have performed pcr
and this case was msi high with
loss the loss of all eight markers
or shifts of all 8 markers pieced
in the micro satellite stable cases
and i also would like to mention the
cutoff is 20
our highest null loss was 9.4 that was
well
above below the cutoff we had
no loss of mmr proteins by
immunohistochemistry in all
except two in one we didn't have
results because we didn't have slides to
do it we only had dna
and in one case we had an indeterminate
result by pc
and by thought it is a false negative
result by from pms2 and we did pcr and
it was actually turned out to be
microsatellite stable so we had in all
the cases we had a match
between what we had found with immune or
pcr
and the results from occur plus
also looking at the msi scores of all
the cases you see here the two
msi high cases well above 20 to 20 cut
off line
and all mss stable cases
were well beyond 19 which is would be to
cut off
for a msi low score
and we didn't have any indeterminate so
far
assessment of human mutational burden we
had
21 samples in 13 we only had results
from ocuplus
in eight samples we had previously
determined
tumor mutational burden with the
oncoming tml lastly
and you see here the samples which we
had results
from human mutational load assay and
plus and you see actually what we think
is a really nice agreement we have
two cases that are high at two samples
that are high
sample 11 is now the inner casting norm
of the colon
and sample three is a decimal plastic
melanoma
we had two samples that were
intermediate and this one is the only
where we have a slight difference
10 is considered the cutter for tumor
mutational burden high
and this was 9.7 and 12.3 in the two
essays respectively however
we think that there won't be a
biological difference and we are also
well aware of the fact that you know
absolutely can compare tml assays
in between samples they perform
the other samples basically distributed
as follows
we had four samples which were in the
intermediate range
one sample another neocrossing norm of
the colon microscopy vitamin stable that
was high
and the old the other samples were low
and we wanted to correlate our tmb high
samples with the msi status
and sample three is a desmoplastic
melanoma
is microsatellite stable and has a high
tmb
and sample eight and eleven are
msi high adenocarcinomas of the colon
if we look now at sequence data we
looked at mlh1 pms2
msh6 and msh2
and you see that case sample 11
here had an mlh
one oops i'm sorry
had a normal h1 premature termination
in codon 319
sample 2 didn't show any mutations
in these mmr genes however it showed a
a p v
600 mutation in vraf and this is of
course well known in the literature
that these tumors exhibit
hypermethylation of the mlh1 promoter
this the desmoplastic melanoma sample
did not show a brav v600
variant however it had the ebrf variant
i would just come to that
and also it didn't show any mutate very
variants
in these um mismatch repair genes
this is now the desmoplastic melanoma
the hist
the histology you see very high tumors
content
and if we look at the variance you see
that we have
a nf1 frame shift mutation we also have
frame fish vegetations in frankie
and cdkn2a in addition we see this vraf
variant in the glycine of 469 this
presumably corresponds to a class
2 b raf mutation and we have
ahrefs variant in glycine13
and these are actually uncommon variants
for
desmoplastic melanomas which are have
more frequent or for melanomas
which have more frequently braf variants
b600
and unrest variance q61
if you look at tumor mutation will burn
in the signature you see that you have
uv signature here with a really high
amount of ct transitions and
our case actually or our sample actually
fits very nicely which was
described in the literature by error
glue
at all and they did whole exome
sequencing of
17 dysmoplastic melanoma samples they
found in all of them a very high tumor
mutational load
and they found over 82
of ct transitions uv damage signature
what we have
and they found that these tumors have
nf1
mutation as their genetic driver in the
absence of the usual
brav v600 and andras q61 hotspot
mutations
so basically our case fits very nicely
into this group
varian calling in the 28
assays we performed before this is
oncoming focus comprehensive and dml
we actually have had found 50 standard
variants
in 29 genes and with ochre plus we had
four out of 57 five were false negative
twice a ct core a and 2a once a ctk and
two b
and one charge promoter alteration
now this would give a sensitivity of
only
92 percent and i have to mention here we
had some childhood
problems we might call it at the
beginning and
we are seeing now better results also we
did a
stereosec control with the seven percent
dna
and we had a perfect match with that
if we look at c and v's that's certainly
our biggest problem at the moment we are
facing in that
we could call cnbs in 17 of 21 samples
however
in less than half of those
or in more than half we had actually an
acceptable
map d value which is below 0.4 but in
slightly
less than 50 it was higher
and we are thinking about actually
moving on to a different dna extraction
protocol sometimes we also get them
tissues from other institutes which have
been fixed informally in in vario
for a very long time and of course we
counter control for that
if you look we had copy number gains in
10 out of 17
samples and in 15 out of 19
we had correct calls if we look at the
false negatives we have three
you see there were all low level
amplifications
of ones cc and d3 and fl
t3 so high level amplifications we
actually we had no problem
and we were in all cases concordant
also there was a false positive richter
which is also a low level copy number
alteration
in summary we had highly reproducible
determination of msi by oncoming
comprehensive assay plus if we compared
results to our immunohistochemistry and
or pcr data
the tmb results which we determined by
oncoming comprehensive assay plus
plus match results previously obtained
with the tml essay
and also the values correlated with the
biological
and or genetic characteristics of the
tumors
for example the msi high tumors were
both high
both displayed high tumor mutational
burden and
also the dismal plastic melanoma as
example
i described before varying calling we
had
53 out of 57 were co-coordinate
and we had as already mentioned the
three false negative
if we compare the data to work of v3 and
one compared to dtml
i have to mention here that this is this
ted variant in detail
very low coverage already in the tml
lastly
now what are the advantages and
disadvantages if we look first at the
disadvantages
we think that the prelim analytical
steps are even more crucial
if you do a large sequencing panel
compared to small
sequencing panels and of course the
analysis is more
is more time consuming however the
advantages
is you have a really fast turnaround you
don't have to send out the tissue with
the consecutive
loss of time the tmb
can be evaluated you do not have to
combine essays anymore
you can evaluate msi status without
requesting that you have a non-tumor
control dna
we don't always have that from
for samples and you can analyze a wide
array of
genes which play a role in pathways
important for oncogenesis
and which actually may be relevant
now what are our plans we really would
like to improve our cnb
calling and as already mentioned just
this improvement of pre-analytical steps
and the goal is cool amplifications more
reliably
and also called relations we haven't
actually started that yet
and we would like to compare our results
in two samples of which we have f1
results and i would like to
thank all the people who work with
me in this team it's constanza francesco
nue me sharing martina and lenka they
work in the laboratory they're really
great and then simone
she is a also more like a pathologist
and the head of the
department is davide and i really would
like to thank all of them and thank you
for listening
all right so thank you very much again
both the speakers
thank you everybody for joining us in
this event today
now we will move on with the q a session
it's a couple of questions for the
speakers
um i'll start actually with avir first i
will first
thank you again for your presentation um
you mentioned that the the the
in in your institution and your
laboratory
is working as a kind of a reference
center therefore also obtaining samples
from
from outside your your own hospital
uh the first question is when you're
working
together with pharmas especially in the
context of clinical trials
can you tell us a little bit a little
bit more about how stringent
and let's say how important is for them
turn around time
i think that'll do guys it's very very
crucial the question thank you for the
question
so i only for clarification i'm working
with pharma but i'm working for the
pharmacist coordinated the accessibility
for the samples to our lab
is not for entering in clinical trials
or we are performing a standard of care
biomarkers such as k rats and raspberry
rough
or eu4 and others in lung cancer
so of course the turnaround time is very
is very crucial here
because you take into account that once
the reference oncological pathology for
the external lab who are ordering these
tests
they are a time that we are not
controlling in the lab so we are a time
for
selection the the best specimen to send
out
and to and also to need to add the time
for the career transportation and also
arrival here maybe four or five days
later
and we started our first day for the
turnaround time as you can imagine
that we need to feedback as soon as
possible if they are
in front of the patients and are
claiming for the results for the
treatment yeah
thank you very much for your question
the second question is as well for you
over here and
you showed some data um where you
actually
comparing fusion detection rate between
different technologies
for instance fish uh or ngs uh
we also take the opportunity to have
enes as a pathologist with ear
us so i will also expand the question to
her how do you see the future of fish
do you see that ngs it's kind of taking
up
more and more space so to say because
you know you can detect multiple
fusion at the same time or do you still
see
fishes let's say the hardcore standard
and ng assets like
on the top as confirmation so what do
you do with valdebro
i think that the i i think that this is
the opposite no i think that the ngs
could be more discovery and also provide
you the informations
in order to follow these saturations but
probably the fees could be more
standard the criteria for the level of
alterations for example
elk lk or roswan is established for 15
of the tumor cells are positive in order
to be positive
and also in ngs you can see oppression
or absence
or maybe you need to count the reits
also performing for this
specific transcript so i think that the
both of them are very very
useful but probably in the future
and next generation sequencing with
these technologies who are
developing new fusion panels uh
discovering new uh
fusion alterations with partners that
are not previously
known but at the end of the day the
split
analysis by face usually is confirmatory
yeah all right thank you very much for
that i don't know if you
agree with me exactly i want you guys
what's from your point of view as a
pathologist
what do you think how things will evolve
let's say in the near future
well i think i mean if if we have ngs
for example
uh fusion or elk we do fish confirmatory
we don't do fish anymore up front
i mean the only place where we do
actually fish at the moment a lot is
breast cancer
because there are you you don't go up
front of course with ngs but i think
that basically
yeah for screening that
basically is not done anymore with fish
like for
for example lung cancer because the
panels are so good and they're so
reliable
and so you really don't need it and
often
fish sometimes on tissue can be really
hard
absolutely and actually this is
a question for you also on something
that you just have mentioned
one of one of the from the audience
there uh they are referring to your
copy number variation and you also just
mentioned breast cancer and you usually
look for her2 amplification whatsoever
what do you see you know again the
future in here do you think that
it will be also the case that a lot of
those testing will be replaced
by the ability of ngs to detect copy
number variant
well basically i mean if you i mean
usually
you have a her2 test you know at the
beginning of the diagnosis and
at the moment the clinicians of course
they don't want to have a huge molecular
analysis they basically want to have
like four or five predictive markers
and that's it and i think for this you
know we will
just stay with fish but i think for
example
for like we just had like a metastasized
um
carcinoma of the salivary gland with
them or p2
and basically these can be easily
screened and there we won't do a firm
efficient i think there it will go away
that's what i think but i think for
breast cancer
i mean you know as long as the
therapy is that what it is and that's
basically a transducer
for estrogen receptor therapy or
anti-estrogen receptor therapy
you don't need a panel you need a panel
once the patient has metastasized
right absolutely thanks for that um
now another question for you in us
that's uh that's a little bit of a
provocative question from the audience
and you know we have heard the
presentation
which was a little bit more on um
targeted sequencing with the mid size
more or less panel
and then we heard yours which was a
little bit more about
large gene panel you know 500 genes
which has tmb
msi and all together how do we combine
those two words together so in other
words if you look for example at the
esmo guidelines which are referred here
in the
in the in the question uh how would you
say
and then also ideally please feel feel
free to to chip in also in the question
would you say you go for a standard mid
size panel
for everything and then for more let's
say complicated case you're for example
cancer of a non-primary
then you will go for a very large panel
what is your approach
uh maybe enos first and then afterwards
i mean basically of course the
clinicians decide we don't decide for
them what they are doing
so and what we are seeing is that
usually they go for a large sequencing
panel if they
have an unknown primary if they have
young patients with metastasis
where they really are desperate to find
some target
and why you basically also don't have
got you know guidelines like for
colorectal cancer or lung cancer you
have really good guidelines but there
you don't have guidelines and
that's basically where they are really
doing these large panels or also
pancreatic cancer they're often very
interested in large panels because
these patients basically don't have a
chance and you just really look do they
fit into a trial can you move them into
a trial
where they might benefit absolutely
makes makes a lot of sense i think uh we
are not sure if you're still there your
image
froze you look very suspicious in the
videos
but please do it uh i'm what's up
no no i said yo yes i have a stick here
yes of course
all right so what what's from your your
side you mean do you agree with what
inna said um
i mean we need to find let's say the
right balance between uh
a large panel and and a more applicable
so to say
mid size panel yeah i think that the
uh i i fully agree with the nsa in this
system so i think that our criteria was
to focus in the
small panels in order to be more uh
accurate in the smaller alterations and
there are
also crucial uh following the guidelines
but also maybe there are some patients
that you
need to to map or to to to
understand more broadly the molecular
alteration behind of these tumors
and also we extend in another
institution here in viro
with an appendix from 300 genes from or
something like that in order to know
exactly
more in deep or more in detail more
potentially
background of these tumor types but
initially we are focusing in small
moderate panels all right thank you very
much again
we have one very very last question we
have only
one minute to go and it's actually about
the genexus
you showed though this is actually the
beautiful video as well
thank you very much for that um the
question
is about in your first let's say
experience in the
in this first few months that you got it
is uh
how flexible the instrument it really is
have you managed to try to use it all in
a single lane or multiple lane
uh how was your experience with that
yeah absolutely flexible so
for uh for our first approach because we
have an a a small experience with the
nexus we acquire recently
and answer we combine different lines
and also within the different lines also
different
programs such as only dna only rna dna
plus rna
and also combining different samples so
the flexibility for our side is is
pretty good so we have also good quality
in the library preparation and the reads
and also
from our side in our short experience
it's quite promising
all right thank you very much that's
actually very good to hear it uh
from again real life experience so now i
would like to close the q a section
thank you again both of you for
participating for your presentation but
also for taking the time to answer to
this question
i also like to thank the audience for
joining us today
and remind them not to leave us the
event is still
going live you can check all the
previous presentation please also check
our posters uh haul and also uh
in about a minute a minute from now we
will have uh michael colleague
andrew who's actually live from our
laboratory in california
he will do a demo about the genexus
integrated sequencer
you can take the opportunity to ask him
a question um
i'll be very happy to answer that and
also uh take the opportunity to
uh get in touch with my colleagues
expert ngs expert that are waiting
for you in our chat room um
once again i would like to thank you all
very much and i'm looking forward for
the next event very soon
have a great day bye thank you
hi